welcome back vectorization is basically
the odds of getting rid of explicit for
loops in your code in the deep learning
error surfing in deep learning in
practice you often find yourself
training on gods of these large data
sets because that's when deep learning
algorithms tend to shine and so it's
important that your code run quickly
because otherwise if you're training on
a big data set your code may take a long
time to run you just find yourself
waiting a very long time to get a result
so in the deep learning error I think
the ability to perform vectorization has
become a key skill let's start with an
example so what is vectorization in
logistic regression you need to compute
Z equals W transpose X plus B where W
was this you know column vector and X is
also this vector maybe they're very
large vectors if you have a lot of
features so W and X will go from these
are n or R and X dimensional vectors so
to compute W transpose X if you had a
non vectorized implementation you would
do something like z equals 0 and then
for I in range of and X so for I equals
1 to n X Z plus equals W I you know
times X I and then maybe you do Z plus
equals B at the N so that's a non
vectorized implementation and you find
that that's going to be really slow in
contrasted vectorized implementation we
just compute W transpose X directly in
Python or a numpy the command is used
for that is Z equals NP m dot W comma X
so this computes W
stalls X and you can also just add B to
that directly and you find that this is
much faster that's actually illustrate
this with a little demo alright so
here's my Jupiter notebook in which I'm
going to write some Python code so first
let me import the numpy library so
import 17 and so for example I can
create a as in array as follows or on
let's say print a now having written
this chunk of code if I hit shift enter
then it executes the code so it created
the array a and it prints it out now
unless do the vectorization demo then
import the time libraries I'm going to
use that in order to time how long
different operations take I'm going to
create an array a this was random not R
and this create a million dimensional
array it was random there the values
vehicles and pins are random dot R and
another million dimensional array and
now ticking equals x or x so let's
measure the current time c equals NP dot
ad let's see talk equals x our time and
let's print this is the vectorized
version right so vectorize version and
so let's print out armed let's see the
last time so let's talk - tick x 1000 so
that we can express this in milliseconds
so unless there's more seconds okay so
I'm going to hit shift enter okay so
that code took about 3 milliseconds or
this time 1.5 okay it may be about 1.5
or 3.5 over seconds at time
so you know it varies a little bit as I
run it looks like maybe on average
taking like 1.5 milliseconds maybe 2
milliseconds as I as I run this alright
um let's keep adding to this block of
code so let's now implement a non
vectorized version let's say C equals
zero then x equals x on time and now
let's implement a formula Phi is range
of 1 million right I've got the number
of zeros right C plus equals a I times B
I and then on talking 12 times our time
and finally print you know with an
explicit for loop um the time it takes
is this 1000 times talk - tick plus 1
oops
m/s just to denote that by doing this in
milliseconds okay oh and actually let's
do one more thing let's just you know
print out the value of C we computer to
make sure that is the same value in both
cases okay so I'm going to hit shift
enter to run des and check that out so
in both cases the vectorized version and
a non vectorized version computed the
same values as you know to 503 six point
99 to 1 the vectors version took 1 point
5 milliseconds the explicit for loot and
non-veterans version took about 400 over
almost 500 milliseconds so the non
vectorized version took you know
something like 300 times longer then the
vectorized version right and so what
this example you see that if only you
remember to vectorize your code your
code actually runs 0 over 300 times
there yeah well let's just run of the
game right is run again yeah vectorized
version 1.5 milliseconds and the
for-loop so 481 milliseconds so again
about 300 times slower to do the
explicit volume so 3x slowdown is the
difference between your code ticking
maybe one minute to run versus it
ticking say five hours to run and when
you are implementing deep learning
algorithms you can really get a result
back faster and then being much faster
if you vectorize your code so some of
you might have heard that a lot of
scalable people implementations are done
on a GPU and a graphics processor unit
but all the demos I did just now in the
Jupiter notebook were actually on a CPU
and it turns out that both GPU and CPUs
have kernelization instructions they're
sometimes called sim D instructions
this stands for a single instruction
multiple data but what this basically
means is that if you use built-in
functions such as this NT dot function
or other per functions that don't
require you're explicitly implementing a
for loop it enables it enables Python
numpy to take much better advantage of
parallelism to do your computations much
faster and this is true both for
computations on CPUs and computations on
GPUs it's just GPUs are remarkably good
at these Sindhi calculations but CPU is
actually also not too bad at them maybe
just not as good as GPUs so you see in
how vectorization can significantly
speed up your code the rule of thumb to
remember is whenever possible avoid
using explicit for loops let's go onto
the next video to see some more examples
of vectorization and also start to
vectorize logistic regression